[Music]
the race is on
we're on a collective mission to
understand and create
artificial general intelligence dr tom
zahavi
thinks that reinforcement learning is
the most general
framework that we have for learning
today
and it could lead to artificial general
intelligence
he thinks there are no tasks which
cannot be solved
by simply maximizing a reward
back in 2012 when tom was an
undergraduate before the deep learning
revolution
he attended an online lecture on
convolutional neural networks
and he was fascinated with their ability
to discover structure
and representations this was an epiphany
for tom
he realized at that very moment that he
was going to become
a machine learning researcher tom's view
is that the ability
to discover and recognize patterns
and structure in data is the most
important aspect of intelligence
two years later he started his phd in
reinforcement learning
just two months after the deepmind
nature paper on the atari games came out
tom was convinced that reinforcement
learning had not yet had its alex
krachevsky
or its imagenet moment he still thinks
that
we need to have something like a cnn
in reinforcement learning this has been
his focus ever since he's particularly
focused on diversity preservation
and also meta gradients to discover
structure
in reinforcement learning what are
metagradients well
to find out you're going to need to be
looking at robert lange's recent blog
on metagradients reading from his blog
now
most learning curves plateau after an
initial absorption of statistical
regularities
the system saturates and we reach the
limits
of handcrafted learning rules and
inductive biases
in the worst case we start to over fit
but what if the learning system could
critique its own learning behavior
in a fully self-referential fashion
learning to learn
how to learn how to learn
introspection and the recursive
bootstrapping of previous learning
experiences
is this the key to intelligence
if this sounds familiar to you you might
have had the pleasure of reading
you again he said in 1987 i believe in
his phd thesis actually
that every self-referential evolving
system should accelerate
its own evolution we can apply meta
learning in the environment we train in
the architectures we use and the
algorithms
themselves so meta gradients are the
third one which is to say
algorithms meta gradients are a learning
approach that allows us to optimize the
inner loop
by maximizing the outer loop we can use
metal learning agents to tune hyper
parameters
to learn options or intrinsic rewards or
other structure
in reinforcement learning now there's a
philosophical question about outer loops
in general
should we have an overseeing kind of
learning agent in an outer loop or
should we be creating a monolithic
approach
where we have some kind of reflexivity
or self-referential modification
when you fractionate the learning into
separate agents doesn't that just create
another set of hyper parameters to
optimize elsewhere
well this is one of the issues that
we'll be discussing in the show this
evening
on reinforcement learning the core
ingredient of machine learning
is generalization right and the the
learning capacity of a model itself
reinforcement learning adds several
complexities to the mix
you learn by taking actions and
exploring in an environment
but you're not allowed to see the
outcomes of the actions that you didn't
take
balancing exploration versus
exploitation is extremely challenging
and reinforcement learning approaches
build on the many decades of literature
in multi-armed bandits and markov
decision processes
they introduced many important
dimensions into the process that didn't
really
exist with supervised machine learning
reinforcement learning also introduces
the concept of credit assignment or
sparse rewards which means that your
learning signal
might not be given for a very long time
after you take action in the system
next you have to overcome deceptive
search bases which is when you can no
longer trust your own compass
to be optimizing in the correct
direction deep exploration or even
exploration with deep neural networks is
something that just hasn't really been
solved yet
sample inefficiency and generalization
are core challenges
last but not least the training dynamics
are non-stable in many reinforcement
learning configurations
and some of the more sophisticated use
of reinforcement learning such as
gradient clipping or
shared representations or auxiliary
tasks these can kind of saturate the
learning capacity of the agents
introducing even more non-stationarity
into the learning dynamics
now meta gradients are one of the ways
to combat some of these significant
challenges in reinforcement learning
metagradients allow our agents to
discover their own way to represent
the world to create agents which
discover structure
and can adapt to their learning
environments dynamically
the fascinating realization for tom was
that getting the meta agents to imagine
a non-stationary reward actually allows
the inner
agent to solve more complex problems for
example
a constrained markov decision process so
metagradients give you an optimizer
that works even better on non-stationary
environments and learning dynamics
we still see a bias variance trade-off
for many of the key architectural design
decisions that we make
in these learning systems for example
which type of gradient do we use
or how many steps do we take in the
multi-step optimizer and
whether we use the same data or
different data in the loss function
tom says that self-tuning with fewer
parameters
implies that less variance is important
whereas learning an intrinsic reward as
a
kind of dnn with many parameters implies
that less
bias is required now meta gradients have
demonstrably improved the learning
dynamics of reinforcement learning
algorithms
and it seems that the more meta gradient
parameters that you add
the better the performance tom also
really likes the idea of
options as a way to model temporal
structure in reinforcement learning
now tom mentions the word options a lot
in today's conversation
and if you haven't heard of options you
can think of options as being kind of a
category
of trajectory in the state action space
so attending a meeting or
visiting a certain room in a game
whereas actions are the primitives
that can be composed to construct
options
anyway i really hope you enjoy the show
today i've learned so much
anyway remember to like comment and
subscribe we love reading your comments
and we'll see you back next week
back to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast
with me tim scarf and yannick lightspeed
de la culture today we have our regular
staff member
robert lange robert is completing his
phd
at the berlin institute of technology as
we've covered previously
robert has arguably the best blog in the
machine learning space
which is robert lange.github.io
he recently published meta policy
gradients a survey
where he investigated the state of the
art of second order policy gradient
methods
also joining us this evening is dr tom
zahavi
a reset scientist at deepmind in london
he's previously done stints at google
facebook
and microsoft no less he holds a phd in
machine learning from the israel
institute
of technology his bachelor's was a
double degree in electrical engineering
and physics from the same institution
tom was
the primary author of the icml paper
graying the black box
understanding dqms where he established
that dqns aggregate the state space
in a hierarchical fashion tom also wrote
the paper
is a picture worth a thousand words from
on using a policy network to switch
between multi-modal product classifiers
in 2016 tom was also involved in the
well-known paper
a deep hierarchical approach to lifelong
learning in minecraft
he was also the author of learn what not
to learn
action elimination with deep
reinforcement learning and in this paper
tom established that sometimes it's best
to learn which actions
not to take he used an action
elimination network to achieve this
and more recently in 2020 tom wrote a
paper called a self-tuning actor critic
algorithm
where he applied meta gradient methods
to self-tune the hyper parameters of an
actor critic loss function
now quoting from rob's recent blog post
what if a learning system could critique
its own learning behavior schmidt huber
said that every self-referential system
should accelerate its own evolution so
tom it's an absolute honour welcome to
the show and why have you been drawn to
metagradian methods recently in your
research
hi hi tim and thanks for the lovely
introduction
um so the reason that
i started to work on meta gradients is
related to
like my big perspective on on how we
discover structure in in machine
learning and
i think that it should be a combination
of of basically three things
uh the environment that we train in the
the architectures that we use and the
algorithms that we have
and i think that meta gradient is uh is
a part of the third aspect the algorithm
so basically it's a method that allows
us to learn something different
in order to solve a problem while
getting better and better in solving the
real problems that that we want to solve
and as a technique we can use it for
example to tune hyper parameters
to learn options or other structure in
reinforcement learning and the
nice thing about it is that it kind of
gives us a very flexible framework to do
many things could you give just a bit of
your intuition
about what the word meta met
meta in the metagrade meta policy
gradient really means
what does it mean to you and what's the
appeal behind it
yeah a perfect question um
so if we look at what is an algorithm
like from from a higher level
perspective it's it's a process that
drives us to learn representations or to
learn predictions
so we get better and better at doing a
task
and if we look at what people were doing
from the theoretical point of view
then we we look for algorithms that will
work in general
on any kind of environment and as a
result we
we have to sacrifice something like we
can't
be as best as we can on a single or on a
particular environment
so if we look at what we are doing in
meta gradients we basically want the
algorithm to adapt
to a given environment and in this
specific environment get
better and better and learn at learning
while it is learning to solve the
problem
and and what is unique about meta
gradients compared to other work in in
meta learning is that we we basically
assume that there is only a single
environment you don't need
this notion of having train and test
environments everything happens in a
single environment and you try to bet to
get
as better as you can for this particular
environment can you maybe
give us an overview of the different
types of meta gradient methods that were
developed in the recent years so
starting with the original paper from
and then sort of yeah your progress and
um
yeah the recent paper and options you
spoke about what are the differences and
how do they all tie together
so i think the the first thing that you
know we need to
distinguish when we talk about meta
gradients is what are the parameters and
what are the meta parameters
and as we start learning more and more
things as we start to learn intrinsic
rewards and start to learn options this
distinction
becomes more and more vague like what
should be learned with the direct
gradient and what should be learned with
the meta gradient
the first work uh by zhongguong shu uh
focused only on
hyper parameters the discount factor and
the lambda return
parameter and then roughly at the same
time there was also a walk led by
zeus zhang that tried to learn an
intrinsic word
so straight from the beginning we had
these two
lines of work one that tried to discover
a specific structure for reinforcement
learning and the other ones that focused
on self-tuning or on trying to
to learn hyper parameters the second
distinction that we usually make is
between
a white box methods and black box
methods
in the white box methods we usually try
to meta learn some aspect of the
reinforcement learning algorithms that
we understand very well
it can be the hybrid parameters of the
algorithm or it can be
the intrinsic reward but it's something
that we already have good intuition
about and
we know algorithms to optimize it
when we go to blackbox methods the idea
is basically to replace all of this
human intuition
and just let the machine to learn
everything so we can model the entire
loss function of the agent with with a
neural network and
and and see if this approach can
discover a new algorithm
and i think that as you go on this axis
like when you do white box meta
gradients
you understand things very well you know
where to start so
so you can do things that are very close
to be a good solution
and as you go to black box methods you
you get
farther and farther from having a good
initialization point
but you also have the opportunity to
discover better things or more novel
things because you don't have this
pile on what you do it's interesting
that you frame it
as there is only one environment so so
to say and you're trying to get better
and better
at learning in this one environment
and i think a natural question is why
don't you just
run like one big learning run
like why if it if there is only one
environment
why do you have to get better at
learning in that environment why
why can't you just you know i take my mu
zero or something my super big
rl algorithm and i just run it once for
a long time
with all the resources that you would
spend on meta learning
the reinforcement learning algorithm
what's the difference between
sort of really learning one environment
and
learning to learn if there is only one
environment
i think we are basically taking both
both of the approaches
so i think and that's basically the last
distinctions that we make
with respect to meta gradients is the
single life time versus multiple
lifetimes um
approach so the multiple lifetime is is
more
a classical meta learning approach where
you have this training environment you
try to learn a better rule
and then apply it on on a test
environment and see if you know just by
training on on some previous tasks you
get better at learning on future tasks
um in the single lifetime type of walks
that
you know um my wall concern on a
self-tuning actor critic is one of them
we are basically doing everything in a
single lifetime so it it basically falls
under
uh your description i think that
the reasons that we are still training
it on a suite of environments and not
only in a single one is basically
because we don't have
like an environment that perfectly
models the world so
basically we are limited by the
environments that we currently have and
if we want to test the generality of the
approach and we don't have this single
environment that gives us all of the
aspects that
that we wish then we can instead you
know run
many instances of it on different
environments and learn more about the
generality of the of the algorithm by
doing by doing it
so i have one question um regarding sort
of
the transfer capabilities of what we met
to learn in this
case right so in a single lifetime you
oftentimes have
sort of a schedule of hyper parameters
that pops out of these meta gradient
approaches
and in the multi-lifetime sort of black
box and cases you have a neural network
that might parameterize an entire
objective and they're no longer these
simple
parameters and to me
maybe correct me if i'm wrong um when
you're in the black box case
it's a lot more cut how to transfer
this discovered objective than in the
case where you have these
um discovered hyper parameter schedules
because they are sort of
more over fit to the problem that you're
actually trying to tackle
yeah um you really need to think about
like this distinction between
transferring and learning
in a single lifetime when you learn in a
single lifetime you basically
want your algorithm to overfit to to the
specific environment
because you want it to learn as as good
as it can in this specific instance and
and if it's the word then you know
you're done like if you have a system
that learns to to learn better and
better
and so in this case uh i don't think
that you want to freeze something and
transfer it
to new environments because you want to
still have this
possibility to adapt to to the given
problem at hand
and when we talk about the classical
meta learning
approach where you you know you have the
training tasks and you want to transfer
something to new tasks then
it it makes perfect sense and then
basically the idea is that you know as a
community we work on this
very defined benchmarks for a long time
and we develop intuition and algorithms
for solving them
and the question is that if we can
replace this part by
black box algorithm that just learns an
algorithm by its own
and i think that you know it poses two
different research questions
and and both are interesting when it
comes to
meta learning especially in the more
classic sense where i
say learn the hyper parameters of an
algorithm or
you know i i learn kind of the loss
function and so on
um i think a natural question is also
the algorithm that you use for this so
the meta algorithm
naturally is also going to have some
hyper parameters
is also going to have some some sort of
you know
intuition behind it and so on uh so
isn't isn't it just shifting the problem
to a higher level and why can it make
sense to
shift that problem why is it is it
easier to tune the
the higher the meta hyper parameters in
a sense
it's also a very good question i think
if we take
a step back and look you know at what
other communities have done
on this type of literature then the
origins are in bi-level programming
and online within online meta learning
um
and then you know let's take for example
the online
learning literature if if your
distribution has some properties
that you know are not the worst case
over the entire world
then you you can hope to get something
by doing meta
learning so for example there's a very
good paper by nina balkan
and they show that for example if all of
the optimal solutions
are in a small area in the solution
space then you can get accelerated
learning just by doing meta learning
and if i zoom back to to meta gradients
the optimizers that we we use for the
for optimizing the meta parameters are
really you know the default thing to do
we use adam with kind of a standard
learning
rate and for my personal experience it
wasn't
too hard to you know tune it or i didn't
spend too much time on doing it
could i slightly reframe what yannick
said because i i think in two questions
yannick is basically
asking the question of should a
monolithic approach suffice
or should we have a modular approach and
we have this argument all the time
in software engineering for example
there are pros and cons
what are the pros and cons for having a
modular approach and having
essentially an outer loop which is
separate
if we go back and think on like why do
we need these two loops and and why we
can't just learn everything and
end to end with a single you know
optimizer um then
the meta gradients they allow you um to
do something
different in order to solve the problems
that you care about
uh and like the framework to think about
it is regularization
and if we think about you know how
people solve supervised learning tasks
then we have the training phase the cost
validation phase
and then the test phase and basically we
allow us
ourselves to optimize something else
than the objective
in the inner loss or when we do training
which is a regularized objective
and then to choose the one that is doing
best
in the outer law so on the you know
cross validation loss which is
an approximate to what we really care
about um
and the reason is that you know some
models are bounded we can't
find the optimal solution with any
approximator so we really need
regularization
you know it's it's a very established
principle in machine learning
and meta gradients give you this
flexible framework
but they do everything online so it's
different you know like from traditional
cost validation because you're kind of
doing online course validation
by doing gradient descent so what
hinders us
from just adding more levels to this
structure right so in principle you
could think of
adding another layer and using meta
gradients to optimize the hyper
parameters
of the meta objective right and
in some sense i'm wondering is the main
limitation
in an explosion in the variance of the
gradients is it an optimization problem
or is there something different that
sort of hinders us from doing this
yeah there are many you know technical
issues in implementing these systems
and i think that you know the the line
of work that we did on self-tuning
focused on
like stabilizing everything showing like
um qualitative properties like stability
and robustness and adaptivity
from what you can gain from doing doing
these methods
and i think that the most interesting
things that you can wish to gain for
meta gradients is this ability to
have a non-stationary optimizer while
you are solving a problem
um if you think you know only on
supervised learning
then you might not need to have a
non-stationary optimizer
but if you go into the rl setup where
the agent discovers
its own data and the data distribution
changes over time
then you you already have some
non-stationarity in the environment
or in the learning dynamics um another
example is constrained mdps
so if you want to solve a constrained
mdp you need to deal with a
non-stationary reward
and then the agent is basically making
the world non-stationary to
you know to solve the problem and and
you have inherited non-stationarity that
you need to deal with and in that case
we also think that meta gradients
really help and the last aspect that
you refer to is stuff like doing
gradient clipping
or another example is shared
representations like if we share
um the laws between the actor and the
critic and
maybe some auxiliary tasks then there
are
cases where you know the capacity of the
agent might not be
big enough to approximate the optimal
solution and because you are sharing
things and because you're using gradient
clipping
you're kind of introducing a competition
on on resources between all of these
different objectives
and in that case it's it's another
example for why
um an agent is kind of introducing
non-stationarity into a learning
into the learning dynamics and and meta
gradients might help to
balance things okay because in my
in my mind the reinforcement learning
problem was always
harder because of the non-stationarity
and supervised learning where you have
fixed targets and a fixed target
distribution at which you just need to
shoot
essentially um is easier but what you're
saying sounds more like essentially that
the additional non-stationarity that you
get from the meta policy gradients
is more beneficial in the case where you
have already non-stationarity in the
inner loop
because it can sort of counterbalance it
is that sort of yeah
exactly like if you have to deal with a
non-stationary problem i think that
there's more hope to gain things from
using metagradients which are
non-stationary by themselves
is is there um is there
so now we're we're talking about having
this outer loop
and an inner loop and potentially having
an
outer loops around the outer loops right
um
could you could you little bit talk
about maybe efforts to
not really have this layer this level
structure but
about optimizer that directly self
modify right so if if i have an
algorithm
that not only does it optimize some kind
of
inner agent that essentially knows
knows nothing about the outer agent but
you can imagine a system
where the meta algorithm directly right
it modifies its
its own parameter its own hyper
parameters do you
is is that a is that a feasible
direction
i think that from the theoretical point
of view if you go back to this online in
online meta learning papers
basically you can do something like that
i'm not sure if when you'll go to write
the code for doing that
it will look that different from the
outer loop
formalism that we haven't and the way we
do implement it at the end
because when we think about the outer
loop the outer loop is basically a way
to say
what is the gradient that we want to
take for the meta parameters to improve
our learning
of learning the parameters in the inner
loop so basically we need to have this
you know taking gradients of gradients
approach which is
uh anything that you know the meta
gradient line of work is about
so i guess you know you can find
other ways to optimize that um but i'm a
big believer in gradient descent and
methods that do gradient descent so
um i personally think that it's you know
the more promising direction
and maybe also follow up question to
this um i don't know if you
if you've seen this work by luke metz so
luke metz had this this year
um i think a very short paper on uh
learning learned optimizers
by sort of improving on themselves right
so this very classic
schmidt uber idea of self-referential
bootstrapping
essentially right and in that paper they
they showed that
the learning dynamics are apparently not
too bad and that you can actually
learn optimizers by sort of starting
from a random initialization right
and what they do is um they they have in
the outer loop i think evolutionary
strategies so some form of approximation
to the actual gradient
um could you say something about how or
why are you using the the true i guess
analytical gradient calculated by
autodiv packages and not an evolutionary
strategy instead is there some reason is
it
variants yeah um
the you know i'm a big fan of theory so
i like to read a lot of theory and
if you look at the origins of
evolutionary strategies and
the concept of creating noisy versions
of your loss function and computing
a numeric gradient from them is actually
well established in in the convex
optimization literature
and the main thing that evolutionary
strategies give you if
you know if you have a convex loss
function and everything is well defined
is that if the function is not
differentiable and so
the the noisy versions give you an easy
way to compute an approximation to the
subgradient and then if we go back to
what this type of methods can give you
that meta gradients cannot
they they can help you to differentiate
meta parameters that are not
differentiable
or that can't be represented you know as
a differentiable function of your loss
and there are quite a lot of exam
examples for meta parameters like
like that like say the bet size or the
size of your experience replay
what are sort of parameters which we
want to
leave untouched by meta gradients right
so you spoke about
experience replay buffers and for
example there you have two hyper
parameters
and sort of the amount of prioritization
you want to do and the amount of
important sampling correction that you
want to do right
and in some sense the way how they go in
is you would have to sample a batch
according to the distribution that you
get from these parameters essentially
and some temporal difference error
but then you would have to sort of
propagate gradients to the stochastic
sampling that's
involved there right is that something
that you want to leave untouched
or yeah what are what are the limits of
meta gradients
when looking at the set of all
parameters that you have in
in reinforcement learning algorithms so
one of the things that we tried to to
achieve when we wrote
the self-tuning actor critic paper was
basically to show scalability
like to take these ideas that john gwen
developed in his first meta gradient
paper and to show that as we tune
more more meta parameters we basically
get better and better
and and we did a very careful you know
ablative analysis on that and and we
were able to show that you know the cam
the performance just keeps improving as
we
self-tune more more hyper parameters
that said
i i do think that you know there are
some meta parameters that
you might um not want to tune
and the reason is basically uh more
related to how you evaluate the meta
gradient so
so as you said like you collect you
collect a batch of data
this data is usually you know if if we
think about this in pall agents and this
data is
at some level of policy and because it's
it is generated by previous actors and
so then for example if you try to
self-tune some of policy in a hyper
parameter
you have the problem that you can't
evaluate it on the things that you
really care about which is you know like
their own policy performance
so there are many challenges you know
like to get it right
but i'm a big believer of tying so like
um
you can expose more and more meta
parameters if you have a
flexible code base uh and if you see
that some things work then
you should think very good with yourself
why
but like i don't like to put barriers
before
i see things could i quickly touch on
robert's previous question about the
evolutionary methods because
i'm a huge fan of kenneth stanley and
he's one of the biggest advocates of
neuro evolution
and open-endedness and diversity
preservation and
he uses the example of a maze when you
have diversity preservation you can
overcome deceptive search spaces because
you kind of allow all of the different
agents to
go down a deceptive search path for
longer before you kind of kill them
so that seems like a really good thing
for me i didn't quite understand why you
said that
that that wouldn't be applicable here i
actually said it will be applicable so
let me
clarify myself sorry so i think that you
know
um specifically evolutionary methods or
the ones that we
were used to tune um by open ai like
the qn agent this type of methods
basically work on
creating noisy versions of your
parameters and then
producing what is basically a sub
gradient of the loss function and and
doing it a
gradient step using this approach so
it's a very good example for methods
that started like from
in the evolutionary community with very
good intuition but basically have like
very well-founded
uh foundations in the convex
optimization literature
so i think that you know it's a method
that should work it's applicable
for meta gradients and it also gives us
the possibility to
tune in non-differentiable hyper
parameters which is something that you
know we can't do out of the box with
with meta gradients at the moment so i
do think there's
a lot to gain from from tying that um
i'm also a huge fan of diversity and
it's something that i'm working a lot
uh about lately and um
i think that you know diversity has a
human quality in it so
uh if you think better like um
why do we need diversity in ni like can
we just find the optimal solution if we
can do it why why do
do we need more more um more solutions
why is
one not enough and i think that the key
is that
as humans we we can never find the
perfect solution we are always bounded
like we
we have limitations and and if we
acknowledge that
then uh finding more solutions that are
diverse which are you know
not necessarily the things that we think
are the best but maybe something that
someone else thinks is the best
is a good strategy for dealing with that
um
so again i i like um
things that come from the convex
formulation so i think that there's
a big hope to also optimize diversity
like with um
in con with convex methods or with
gradients it doesn't necessarily have to
to be an evolutionary method at the end
but the type of methods that you know
you choose to walk is basically
the ones that you are more excited about
at the end with
with with optimizing diversity though
there is
what people usually do in reinforcement
learning is they add something like an
entropy regularizer or something like
this and it
always appeared to me like that would
yes that would give you some diversity
in solutions or also
you know what you said what dqn does
which is you do
some some kind of a noisy version of
your parameters and then you evaluate
that
uh it always seemed a little bit not
really satisfying to me
because essentially what it does if it's
if you have your solution
kind of attractor base into the you know
the solution that is given by the
gradients
it seemed to me like this these types of
things would just sort of
fuzz this a bit like give you kind of a
gaussian bump
around it but not really uh go for the
the types of diversity we see in in
these you know these
evolutionary algorithms where you really
diverge in
not not only like a little bit but
fundamentally different approaches to
solving problems
do you have an opinion about what can
except for
evolutionary methods what can get us to
like
really qualitatively different solutions
to to problems
so i think the question is where you
want to end
if you want to end with um for example a
set of policies that solve
a given problem at different ways then
there is a way to formalize that and
if you look for example at the line of
work on
variational intrinsic control and
diversity is all you need
so this type of works basically
try to maximize the entropy of the set
so you want
policies that visit different states and
if
that's where you want to end up you can
actually write you know a convex problem
for doing it and optimize some intrinsic
rewards that will lead you
to get there we had a recent paper in in
iclear trying to to do something like
that
more from a robustness perspective the
mutation part or the evolutionary part
is is a process that can give you that
it's usually harder to give guarantees
on how fast will it do it or how will it
scale
when when you start to work on things
from the optimization point of view then
you can get better intuition
on are you doing the right thing or how
much time will it take you to reach this
optimal diversity that you want
that's why i'm like a bigger fan of this
type of methods
so something that i discovered in in
multiple
pieces of your work is that in some
sense
in in stacks there are multiple tricks
how to render
more of the reinforcement learning
pipeline um to be exposed to
meta gradients right so um you make
the v trace sort of operator
differentiable
and you add multiple heads to to your
architecture to have sort of more
parameters to tune with meta gradients
and is there sort of what's your your
mindset when figuring out these things
or
how do you approach the problem of
getting the most out of meta gradients
i think you should always be motivated
about something and
and when i i started to work on on
stackx my motivation came from
this idea of learning with multiple
discount factors
there was you know work on that before i
started to work on stockx
with good examples on a rainbow agent
uh and if you think uh more deeply about
it
a discount factor actually approximates
the planning horizon of the agent like
uh that's the horizon that you are
willing to make your plans up to
something that goes like
one minus a one over one minus the
discount factor
so if you think about games like chess
if you are limited by your planning
horizon you will get up different uh
plants or different uh chess strategies
and this you know like general
motivation was what motivated us to
start working on stackx
because we believe that you know if
we'll have many discounts
then maybe some of them will decide to
be shorter
they will allow us like to discover
shorter plans on how to be
locally optimal and maybe making these
predictions will make it easier for the
agent to
to derive larger plants or or deal with
harder problems and i think that you
know in all of the meta gradient works
we always started with
a problem that we understood very well
if it's the intrinsic reward work if
it's the options work
so it's it was a problem that we studied
for a long time in the reinforcement
learning community
and and then the meta gradient instance
came to to deal with
you know certain uh tuning aspects or
or certain details that you know we
didn't like to
to be too much obligated to to have them
pre-tuned or predefined
in one of the the figures where you show
essentially the different hyper
parameters
um for these three hats right um it
seems like the first hat which is the
one which acts in the environment
has a very distinct hyper parameter like
a larger discount
while the um the other two sort of have
very similar
hyperparameters um and i was wondering
in some sense uh
why is there then the third has if
basically just the second head could do
the job
what what is different about the
learning dynamics yeah
we did try you know to run it with other
configs or to
to search over this number of auxiliary
tasks this was the main
new hyper parameters that the
architecture had because when we had
this new auxiliary task that's basically
the only thing that we need to to add as
a new hyper parameter because everything
else
remains the same um three worked better
than two
and better than a higher value so it was
an empirical finding
but if you look at how this hyper
parameters tune
uh so you are collected in in many of
the games they tune exactly to the same
values but not in all of them
so so we were able to find games where
you know each one of them tuned to
different values
and the algorithm was able to discover
these different like three different
planning horizons
taking a step back before you said
robert said something maybe you want to
leave the batch size alone because
you need to sample differently or you
know there are some parameters
that is that are tricky to get uh from
from the discrete domain to the
differentiable domain
there are approaches where you just try
to
learn proxies for these things like you
you try to learn
new so instead of making the things
differentiable which is what you usually
have to do in meta learning
you try to learn some kind of proxy
neural network
for them which is differentiable right
could you
tell a bit about how how do these
approaches usually
work and why don't we use it for all the
things that are not differentiable
because it seems like you know it seems
like a good idea just you know have my
neural network there that approximates
it and
boom yeah it's it's a great idea uh
i don't think there is any reason not
not to try it
uh it's actually something that you know
have been on our minds
uh uh to try i think that the complexity
of your system will grow
when you'll stop doing things with
gradient descent so if you need to
approximate non-differentiable things
um it it will require walk and and more
tuning to get it
to work right uh while the meta gradient
type of work you know when we focus only
on the differentiable things
is really quite simple um so i'm just
saying that you know there's um
a bow that you need to to cause if you
want to go to this uh other
regime and janet could i um put that
back to you though so if you did have a
surrogate model which describes
a model which was non-differentiable and
then you you know took the gradient of
the surrogate model
if the model was basically just
memorizing lots of stuff that it's
trained on
why would the um the gradient of that
surrogate model be meaningful
well you'd you'd sort of if you think
about the batch size right you'd
you just kind of run a bunch of runs
with different batch sizes
and that automatically gives you a
training set
for a neural network that has the batch
size
and maybe some other parameters as an
input right and then it has
as an output something you care about
like you know you could directly it
could directly be the performance or it
could be
the output for some some other part like
uh for example if you tune the batch
size
uh the output of could actually be the
batch
right because that's what your sampling
process it takes a batch size and gives
you
a batch right so you could train a
neural network in principle
to um take in the batch size as a number
and output a batch of data that could be
you know actual data or it could be
data in in latent space you know already
at like layer one or two of the neural
network
uh that it's going into but technically
it's feasible uh to train that and and
then you could
perfectly right back propagate and
predict what's the optimal batch size
uh or how do i need to adjust my batch
size to get a better training signal but
i see that the complexity of course is
is huge
in that because you know and it depends
on
how accurate such a a surrogate model
can even be
but you know given the fact that deep
learning has been
super duper successful in so many things
it might as well be successful in these
things and i mean i think there are also
multiple examples in neuroscience where
people use
surrogate gradients or surrogate models
to approximate the discontinuity
of spikes right where in the forward
pass you treat it as
non-differentiable and just have your
step function but in the backward pass
you put something smooth
over it essentially right so you have
different forward and backward
operations essentially and i think um
synthetic gradients are another example
where people try to to make this work
right to a certain degree
coming sort of back to a point that we
had in the beginning of sort of
multi-lifetime versus single lifetime
and in a single lifetime you want
essentially to overfit to the
environment that you're sort of
tasked with while in the multi-lifetime
you want to be able to transfer
essentially right
and i was wondering um another key
difference between these two is that in
the one case you do the
sort of the online cross-validation that
you spoke about tom
on the train environment and then the
other you do the online cross-validation
on the test environment
so so that in the multi-lifetime case
the test environment really sort of
dictates dictates what the meta gradient
essentially
tries to distill into the optimization
process right
can you talk about sort of design
choices of what test environments
to pick or how should should i choose
the set of environments so that most of
the
rl specific optimization problems or
problems are sort of captured
so like i think this answer basically
also answers the
the previous question by anik lake i
think that with this type of techniques
we should be able to to learn everything
at the end
so if if our training suite of tasks is
wide enough and the real world is
and it captures the reward at the end uh
so we bake and we learn uh long enough
we can basically
you know learn everything that that we
want
but but then you know when you take back
and and you zoom into what we are
currently doing
then there are limitations the
environments maybe not diverse enough to
represent
the test uh perfectly
maybe we just you know in a single
lifetime maybe we just need to
learn things fast enough so it becomes
useful and improves the the performance
so it doesn't say that you know if we'll
have 10 times more budget
we can't learn more things it says that
you know
from our experience in the you know
feasible
frame budgets and that's the things that
we were
able to to learn um and
you know it's it's a trend that you see
all over the machine learning
or the deep learning community that
you're basically
you know limited by all data in what you
can
discover uh in the meta gradient case
it's a bit different because the agent
discovers uh discovers its own data
but when you think on the meta
parameters you do need
enough time to for the algorithm to pick
up and
so so the only question is how is it to
learn these type of parameters so it
will pick up
fast enough you know looking at your at
your uh google scholar profile here
the the most cited papers of yours is
actually the uh deep hierarchical
approach to
lifelong learning in minecraft which
always makes me wonder whether or not i
should
convert my channel into a minecraft
channel it would probably
be much more popular um could you talk a
bit
because that is it what's special about
it is it from 2016 which is
you know it's like an a a lifetime ago
in terms of
it's it's one phd ago right um
and a lot has changed since then what
what could you
describe a bit the paper and what you
did there because
you know like did we even have red we
had resnets right but
it was still like limited
yeah so it's it's fun to go back in time
to to
these days uh so just to give a short
into like i was a phd student in d
parallel before
you know it was after deepmind released
the first icml paper on dqn
but before the nature paper went out so
everything was like magic
in these days and i i had a single
computer with a single gpu
and i ran the qn and i saw it play you
know and i started it
for for four hours like trying to
understand what it's doing and how it's
playing
uh and it and i was reading you know
other literature on reinforcement
learning and specifically on structure
because i was interested in in
discovering structure
and i really liked the the idea of
options and
as a way to model temporal structure
reinforcement learning
but we didn't have you know environments
that we can control or we can ask
very well um carefully picked questions
in them and because of that minecraft
was appealing because we
we could basically build our own words
in it and ask questions about it
and there was no you know zoom a doom or
dm lab
environments at this time so what we did
is is basically we
supervised an undergraduate student
project uh
and the first authors of this paper were
undergraduate students working on
minecraft at this time
and they built everything in minecraft
and the agent interface that we used for
this paper
was actually doing print screen to
capture the
the the image input for the agent and
so it was that preliminary in these days
uh we later switched to use the malmo
repair which microsoft released after we
wrote the paper so we did reproduce
everything like you know within a
normal input but it was like very
exciting days because it wasn't known
what is possible to do what is not
possible to do
and and this specific paper tried to you
know to introduce options or to
introduce
hrl into into deep real agents which was
something that
you know was not possible at this time
and to show us a proof of concept that
we we can do these things
um if if you think about
something like minecraft and if you
think about how
how humans go about you know
playing minecraft essentially um of
course there there is an aspect of
let's say meta learning in that i go
look up on the internet what other
people do
right but essentially you could you know
you could give me a copy of minecraft
and
i could you know get along fairly well
in there
play a bit and i would never have to
restart the game right
unless i play on hardcore but you know i
die i
wake up again i try again and so on
um and this is more as like the paper is
also called lifelong
lifelong learning what are what are your
your current thoughts what is if you had
to design
um maybe not constrained really by
current compute but you know not not np
hard um if you had to design the perfect
algorithm
for lifelong learning in something like
minecraft
what would that look like if you know in
your in your mind from what you've
learned
since then the interesting thing about
minecraft is
is that you know as a human you don't
have explicit reward
in the game right like you can basically
do whatever you want
um but the thing is that you know as
humans we do have some intrinsic
motivation to do uh lots of things uh
and we get joy you know by building
things or getting to new areas
and it's a hard question to think about
an ai
in this game because you know it doesn't
come with all of this increasing
motivation
unless you code it um and now there's a
question if
you know when you are going to build an
agent and you want
it to live in the in this world uh are
you going to evaluate it
as a human like are you going to say
this ai is intelligent because it's
building things and doing things that i
care about
and if so how do i tell it to do it like
how do i encode the intrinsic motivation
that i have
into the agent uh and does
do i give it as an extrinsic reward and
do i give it as
a mechanism to discover intrinsic
rewards so that there are many questions
uh like to to think about here um
i think that we need agents that are
able to discover these
intrinsic motivations but i also think
that you know the world should have
lots of rewards like i personally think
that the the world have many dense
rewards and and the challenge is
actually to choose between all of these
sources of reward and and i don't think
that
as humans we experience the world as a
very sparse reward game where
we only get feedback when we finish
goals and
so and the meta gradients does come into
the picture here because we can have
this
very rich mechanism that allows the
agent to learn these intrinsic rewards
and find its own way to define sub goals
and options and
and all of these things that we did in
order to get better in in living in the
in this world and um but so how would
and i'm thinking more about you know the
real world
ais right um they if
because i've i've for a while i've been
thinking about something like
let's say big companies like
google or something like this in a sense
they are
sort of organisms too and they are
organisms and you can say okay we live
in capitalism
so but it's not really true right these
because they they in a way because
they're also
monopolies uh they shape the structure
of the market themselves
um so and an ai
that lives in the world do you think we
could even
recognize something if it wasn't
explicitly made to be
human or do you do you think that would
be recognizable
uh or will we just think like uh this
this stupid computer is
doing i don't know like what would what
would
a self-discovering intrin
intrinsic reward system look like and
could we recognize it or do we need to
explicitly say it must be like a human
yeah it's a great question um
i think the general question is that how
will we reach agile or like even
is that possible and then the question
is like
when will we say that something is an
aji right like if it will do things that
look to us intelligent will probably say
that it is but then
let's say that we discovered an agi and
you now
let the agi to discover a new agi
will it have the same test like for
intelligence right
um and and i think that not like i think
that you know there's no
one uh formulation or one definition for
intelligence like we perceive it in a
certain way and and will consider
intelligent things that
do this type of things but we should not
constrain the the ai or the agi
at the end to be like us um
the the more tricky question is how do
you reach that right like what is the
pest
to reach ai or agi and there i think
that you know we are limited
as researchers to to things that we are
excited about the things that we
think are intelligent and to reach that
we we must have some level of
interpretability or
uh criticism to say this thing is is
doing the things that i think are
intelligent
i think that also diversity gets into
the picture here because
um i think that at the end we want
the i not to only be good you know at
maximizing scores we want it to to look
more natural to us to be more creative
to do other things that we are able to
do as humans
and if we you know care about these
things from this point we'll
when we'll reach some some level of ai
it will have other human qualities in it
as well and not only the the
like the um characteristic to solve
things just to touch on that
because we've got francois charles
coming on this show soon i'm not sure if
you've read his measure of intelligence
paper i'm only allowed to invoke his
name once per show
so i'll do it now but he says that
intelligence has embodied so it's a
process it's not a brain
and he says that intelligence is the
information acquisition efficiency and
generalization so
in in a roundabout way he basically says
that reinforcement learning isn't
intelligence because
intelligence must be normalized by any
knowledge and experience that you give
it
so in a way he's kind of trolling
reinforcement learning i mean
do you have any opinion on that
i think that you know the foundations of
reinforcement learning are definitely
about
intelligence it's about how fast you
collect your data to get better and
better
in the world and how you you know uh
diminish your uncertainty about the
world and get more and more information
about it so it's it's definitely about
intelligence
uh i also agree with the point that you
know um
a brute force approach for planning is
not intelligent
and you see examples for that in chess
you know like we chess was able to get
better than humans
right with brute force uh force
approaches but
grand master didn't thought that the
chess engines or
deep blue type of chess engines are
intelligent and when we try to tackle a
harder
game like go we weren't able to do it
like with a pure brute force uh
approach and we had to get some learning
or some pattern
understanding into these machines to get
better and better at more complex
problems so i completely agree with the
the idea that we should discover
patterns and we should use information
efficiently but i think that you know
reinforcement learning is all about that
so maybe then the the completely
contrarian opinion is david silver's
hypothesis on reward is all you need
right in the sense that for him
i hope i don't misrepresent this year
um the rewards or the reinforcement
learning formulation
is basically everything that we need to
to capture
yeah intelligence in some form of way
right we might not have the right tool
set right now
the right algorithms the right
architecture is what you spoke about in
the beginning
but but do you think this this is a
different point of view that one can
can arguably have is there something
missing from sort of the
problem formulation that we have right
now
so i don't think it's in contrary at all
i think that you know reinforcement
learning is very general
why it's general because you know it has
the generalization aspects of
of supervised learning but it's adding
to the equation
three more important things one is
exploration or online learning
which is about how you learn from
actions if you are not allowed to see
the outcomes of all other actions
how do you do balance exploration and
exploitation efficiently
so reinforcement learning is basically
building on everything that was done in
in the bandit literature and later in
the theoretical community on on mdps
to have another aspect that you know
classical supervised learning
systems does not have and the third axis
that is important in in reinforcement
learning is the credit assignment
how can you learn um about the actions
that you take on the present from
outcomes that you see in the future so
each one of these aspects like
exploration and credit assignment
basically take the the basic you know
supervised learning learning theory
point of view
on how systems uh learn and extends them
like in in two aspects uh and now you
can say
like other problems that i can't solve
with these three in
indigenous attempt i think that you know
meta gradients or online within
online matter learning is one way to to
extend it
uh and there might be others uh but the
questions that we need to ask
ourselves is are there problems that we
can't solve by maximizing reward
uh and i'm not sure that there are like
if you look at
the convex optimization foundations
again then you can solve any convex
problem
if it's defined on an mdp by maximizing
reward
uh by you know calling to a linear
you can think about maximizing reward is
calling to a linear oracle
and then you can basically do things
like gail
or solving constrained mdps you know all
of these small complex problems were
basically
solved at the end by maximization of
reward
and i think it's an interesting point
because
it's basically very general like um i
think that finding
um instances that you can't solve by
maximizing reward is is going to be hard
i'm not saying that there aren't but i'm
saying that the framework is
perhaps the most general that we have at
the moment on the reward is all you need
i i also don't think there's any
conflict there i think what chile points
out are two things it's
the fact that to build an intelligence
with that framework you would need to
have unlimited prize and experience
but the other thing charlay talks about
i think he's he's focusing in on the
substrate of neural networks
he says that the type of generalization
you have in your networks is what's
called a kind of continuous
generalization
and he wants to move to something called
a program-centric generalization which
is thinking about
reusing modules in graphs thinking about
programs as
as being graphs and being able to
identify isomorphisms in graphs
and he thinks that that kind of
generalization and topological
space will be significantly better than
using the substrate of neural networks
yeah so you know i started to work on
on deep learning when it was not that
popular and people questioned you know
like the generalization capabilities of
deep networks for a long time
uh i think that we are starting to
understand better on on how deep
networks generalize like if you look at
the double descent curves
or the lottery hypothesis people start
to understand better why
this interpolation that deep networks do
between the the points that
they memorize is actually something good
and it can generalize very well
i don't think that you know we have the
best um theory
at the moment on on how they do it and
it's possible that
you know people will come up with other
structured ways to
to capture patterns and generalize with
them you know
if if someone is excited about trying
other ways
that's that's the way to go you know
like even with deep learning it started
by people saying
don't do that so like if someone has a a
new idea and he wants to replace that
part
i wish he will succeed you know and and
will progre progress as a community
i personally i believe that you know at
the moment that's the best models that
we have
and that's why i'm excited to be to work
with them because i like to to build
things and and see
what they do i think that looking at how
to discover structure
is the main thing that drives us forward
in the machine learning communities
like a couple months ago sarah hooker
had this blog post on the hardware
lottery
right where she spoke about how the
current sort of state of the hardware
that we have is
very much influencing the scientific
ideas that we try out
and sort of also the scientific ideas
which never make it
to fruition in some sense and when i
look at
most of the metagradient work it's very
strongly built on jax and on tpu support
which ideas are we missing or which
ideas are there still
sort of um looming in the method
gradient work
or world or sort of which ideas are the
ones that
can most benefit from the hardware that
we have right now
so so the there's definitely a
correlation in the community you know
between the software and the hardware
that we have to the things that we can
solve
uh i think it's also a matter of
excitement like once you are very
excited about
an idea you'll start to develop a code
base and if you can make other people's
uh excited about it then you'll get
support from the community and
will develop new software for doing new
things
jack specifically is amazing for you
know
its autodiv capabilities and its
vectorization
and it it makes things um with meta
gradients much easier
like it's not that they weren't possible
before
but what we did before was basically to
compute many of the gradients by hand
and
and then to code them and now we can
just you know
um write a base agent that has an outer
loop and an inner loop and then you just
write things in terms of
of the loss of the outer loop and the
loss of the inner loop and that's the
only thing that you need to do
and it gives you a way you know it's a
group that is working on these things to
to scale things up quicker and test more
ideas and
make more progress um so i think you
know it's only
it's not only about like the type of
software that we have it's also about
like getting people
excited about an idea and writing new
software
um the second part you know is the
bitter lesson like we we do see that
uh as a community uh methods that use
more compute
uh get better uh over time it doesn't
mean that we need to use the compute
in a dumb way right like we want to use
compute efficiently and that's exactly
like
what alphago did to to search uh methods
that did brute force
compute didn't exceed it at go and and
we had to get
better learning algorithms and write the
software to do it and and now we are
able to to do learning in
in new domains where it wasn't uh
possible before
i also think that you know like this the
ways that the community works that we
focus on on specific benchmarks
is a way that works as a community like
even if you know specific works
at specific times uh only try to push
the thought
results as a community we see progress
so it's not
always about like this single paper that
gets
the state of the art it's about how we
make progress as a community and how we
uh dwell on the ideas that actually
stick at the end
in speaking of the community and so on
do you see
any concerning trends right now anything
where you say
uh probably too many people are going
into this
into this direction and it's it's pro
it's probably not such a good thing
maybe the rewards you know the rewards
in the real world aren't really aligned
with progress
do you see anything that that worries
you at the moment about the research
community in
in rl i think that we are a fantastic
community
like you know there are so many people
coming from so
diverse backgrounds and you know people
coming with backgrounds
in physics and in mathematics and people
that like theory and people that like to
do experiments
uh when we meet at a double blind review
system
uh sometimes it takes the the bad part
of us like you know
i like to do experiments and i will
criticize something someone that is
doing theory
or you know like we tend to think on
things from our own eyes and not as a
community
but uh at the end i think that we are
making a great progress
and that you know ideas that are
developed uh by different groups
eventually end up
at the same conferences and and people
over time do learn from
from each other and
you know there are days where i
criticize and where you know i
i had a conference where none of my
papers was accepted so i was very
[Music]
anxious or i don't know but uh at the
end i think that we are a great
community
but on the other hand do you do you
think there are directions where not
enough people are going into
um maybe maybe of course you know your
directions
but do you see other opportunities that
you
not necessarily want to pursue yourself
but where you think wow that's really
underexplored
so you know deep learning is is a
perfect example because there were times
where people were encouraged not to work
on that and today everyone is encouraged
to work on that and it's not in cards to
work on other things
uh it's a question of risks like uh if
you want to work on something that is
not popular then it's a high risk high
gain
and everyone needs to decide for himself
if if he wants to do it like
i engaged in projects that i thought
that there are high risk high gain
at the bottom line it's it wasn't that
hard risk and the gain was
wasn't that big neither you know it it's
something that you need to think about
as a community we do tend to prefer you
know incremental walks or walks that
build on previous uh research
and then again i think that the
important thing is the progress that the
community makes and not the progress
that each paper makes
like you can see many papers that you
know only change 10
10 lines of code or only wrote a new
analysis for an existing algorithm
but then if you if you look at how
things were five years ago
then as a community we made tremendous
progress so
you know it's not saying that
everything's perfect but
i do think that you know a lot of things
are going uh
as a phd student in reinforcement
learning myself um
i wonder if it's feasible to go into
metagradient work right
it's a very good question because i was
in your
situation like you know two years ago i
i also did like a phd in
in deep reinforcement learning and i had
to you know think this
about these questions with myself um
specifically for the meta gradient work
um one aspect of it is
that we all we only use online online
agent
so you know in palo 8 or 83c it's
basically you know the
less compute heavy agents that that we
have if you compare it to a dqm then we
run
eight times less computations you know
per data point because we are not using
experience to play at all
i would say that it is a reasonable um
agent to work on a form a phd the
the the second part is that you know as
a phd student it will be harder to get
uh
results on all 57 atari games and and
that's perfectly reasonable
and and because of that i think like i
would recommend to focus on the
qualitative
properties like to start with domains
that we can
carefully think about and gain
intuition about what's going on in the
try to you know
study the uh very specific aspects and
and then you know if you can't do the
entire 57 then
then do a subset and and it will be
perfectly fine
um i think it's it's it's a bigger
question like
because if we take the bitter lesson and
and we want to work on you know like
methods that use a lot of compute
because that's the methods that
exceed the most like do we need to use
all of the computes that we have
any single experiments that we do or can
we gain intuition from doing smaller
scale experiments and
and also progress the community from
doing so
and i think that there is room for both
if you have access to compute then you
are allowed to do you know
to to study this regime and focus on
that if that's what you're excited about
because i think that you know at the end
that that's what will drive us to agi
but i also think that you know we are
building on ideas that were developed in
in more carefully uh test cases or in uh
the developing tuition and um there's a
lot to to learn from
from reading papers like that and as a
community you know we can gain a lot
from it
so there is a wonderful article called
deep reinforcement doesn't
work yet by alex urpan in 2018 and he
was
he was saying basically that he was
working at google brain for about six
weeks and it took him
all of that amount of time just to get a
basic pendulum policy working and it
still didn't work very well
it's uh non-stable training and even if
it does work
it probably won't work 70 of the time
and it's not reproducible and it's
sensitive to the random seed and the
sample and efficiency and
the reward hacking and the tldr is that
um what might not be clear to our
audience is that you three are in the
top one percent right there are
there are kind of power laws in talent
and just to work with reinforcement
learning you have to be
incredibly smart and people like deep
mind and open ai they hoover up all of
the talent
and it's it's one thing for you folks to
be working on deep reinforcement
learning but from my position
i'm in industry and people are excited
about reinforcement learning and they're
saying we should be doing reinforcement
learning projects
and my advice is no don't do it and
people like microsoft have cottoned onto
this and they created a reinforcement
learning platform called bonsai which
you know explicitly abstracts away the
complexity of
dprl and uses this concept called
machine teaching to kind of
create building blocks of how to build
drl agents and so on in my opinion it's
completely inaccessible to the average
person or data scientist in industry
would you agree with that
again i was in both sides so so i did
you know a five year phd
in a small lab i had let's say four
gpu machines at the beginning growed to
be
around eight but you know like a single
computer that i bought i installed the
gpu on it i did the cuda installation
everything like when it wasn't that easy
um and i did deep real research with
this
uh budget uh and you know i got
papers accepted and i think that some of
these ideas helped for the community or
i see people building on these papers so
i don't think it's only about
who has more compute but i think that
you know if you don't have enough
compute you should
be honest about it and constrain
yourself to the type of questions that
that you ask and that you work on in my
case
like it was about you know trying new
domains trying new ideas
doing some combination of theory and
practice because
you can't just you know run on the the
all of the 57 atari games
as you say the the second thing that
happened to me was when i joined
deepmind and i
was able to to do all of that uh so
if i take the stockx paypal for example
um i didn't use too much resources for
tuning
actually the things that i used the most
resources for was to gain better
understanding
on what's going on and this was kind of
like understanding that now when i have
the compute resources
i want to communicate uh the conclusions
that
that i can to back to the community so
for example the ablative analysis that
we did
and we got you know like the sort of
performance we got
into it without doing ablative analysis
uh but once we got this very high score
senator
we we went back and we said okay we have
this computer let's understand
how the method works back better and try
to communicate that
to to the communities and and by doing
so trying
try to make them convinced that it's
something that they should try
themselves
um
and more generally i personally think
that you know reinforcement learning
works
um like every problem that i try to
solve
eventually like i managed to get
learning or i managed to do something in
it
i do think that as a community it's not
at the point where supervised learning
is and
basically because we have more
challenges and and we are looking for
solutions to these challenges
if you think about exploration so we
don't have a good solution for
deep exploration or exploration with
deep nets yet um
and there are other problems uh that we
we are currently tackling
uh so it's not clear if we got the
optimal solutions
and i do think that we'll get we'll see
more progress coming up
uh in these years so it's not industry
ready
uh in that in the sense that you know
you can take off the shelf algorithm
and it will just work uh but i think
that you know
if you're a professional and and you
work with the systems
and you are very likely to succeed in uh
in solving reinforcement learning
problems with the algorithms that
we currently have speaking of you know
um
less resources and so on i was reading
also a bunch of a bunch of papers from
back in the day let's say the the 80s
and the 90s and so on
and it was incredible to me that
sometimes
these people they had an idea of what
you know
should be done on a high level they had
a little bit of math maybe
maybe not and then they had like a
little bit of a pseudo code
pseudo algorithm and if sometimes
sometimes synthetic you know really
synthetic data
uh to to work this stuff out and um
do you do you think it would be a good
thing if we sort of revived a bit more
of these
sort of concept papers idea papers and
so on
or do you do you think there is
something to
actually getting down and doing you know
either real theory or
real experiments with limited compute
but still
you know actually proving something we
should be
honest with ourselves if the the way we
write papers is actually
making us to to make progress as a
community
uh i personally very like innovation so
like if
a paper had like a very good idea back
in the 90s
then i i think that this ideas will stay
and we'll leave it with us even when we
have more compute
and you know we mentioned that you know
when i started to do deeper l
there wasn't deep really yet and i
organized a reading group
and we had to write to read papers from
the 90s because there were no papers
in the 20s and you know we gained a lot
of intuition from from reading
these papers and a lot of inspiration
but when it comes to
what should we do today again it's it's
what you're excited about
i really like to build systems uh and to
see
by by my eyes like what they are doing
and um
to debate with myself about it so that's
the kind of work that i'm excited
about that i will read that i will build
on if you are
only excited about uh getting new ideas
that's also fine
the hardest thing is you know like how
to evaluate an id
like if you are only putting it on paper
and and that's for the community to to
decide right like
experiments is one thing mess is there
is another way to to validate that and
id is
uh interesting i i think it goes back to
to a discussion with before about
non-stationarity
so i think that many production systems
have a non-stationarity
aspect in them uh so for example i did
an internship at
walmart.com and we had a you know a
catalog with offers
and the catalog was being updated you
know regularly based on the season
best based on the holidays uh so
what people do is basically they retrain
the model you know like
when the data distribution changes uh so
i think that you know there's a big
gain to to gain from doing a meta
learning approach
in these non-stationary systems google
maps was another example where there
were
other non-stationarities in in the
problem and meta gradients
helped it can also be like the boundness
principles that we talked about before
you know some resources are shared
and the agent is creating some some
non-stationarity
to the learning dynamics because it's
smaller because it can't perfectly fit
the world
um so i i do see gains from
meta gradients in in other systems that
are not completely reinforcement
learning systems
uh but i do see them being used more and
more
in environments that are known more and
more non-stationary
and do i trust the code base i i trust
it uh very much so
so i basically most of the new papers
that i write even if they are not
uh with meta gradients i use my own code
base because
you know we do have this bias to to
prefer our own agents
because we know like every bit uh in it
but uh
i found it to be very reliable and very
robust
i was really intrigued by your paper i
think it was in 2011 you know the the
one where
you wanted to discover structure and the
dqn agent
of which was trained on breakout and you
did a disney projection and you actually
realized that there was a hierarchical
state space right i mean
how how did you even start to go about
doing that that must have been
fascinating
yeah so so the background is that you
know
we we saw the dq in nature paper and
there was this
you know fascinating tsne images in it
and and they you know
when you look at something like that you
you basically
think that there is some structure in it
like um to uncover
and the question was what kind of
structure um do we have
in it and my supervisor i remember uh
shaman oh he sent me an email and he
said like we should look more and more
at structure
uh at what star structure these systems
uh learn
and and i i had a bias towards you know
like a structure that was being explored
in the reinforcement learning
community so specifically aggregated
states and options
and we just you know asked the results
uh the research question like
can we find this type of structure in
this dsn images so can we do it
so we started with testing type of
approach like we just took the system we
built a lot of human knowledge
around it like we had coded features and
we
created clusters in the feature space
and we wanted to see if we can
you know uncover some of the structure
and
we succeeded like we and we were quite
surprised by that like we found that one
cluster that corresponds to carving the
tunnel
and you know like if you play breakouts
and you can carve the tunnel and let the
ball go above the bricks
so we were able to uncover a cluster
that focused on this and there was three
clusters for options that
tried to cover the the tunnel and then
you know we moved to another domain
like sequest and we found clusters for
filling air and for killing monsters
and for collecting divers so like
very very specific you know or
hierarchical behaviors
uh like a way a human would approach it
so it was on only post analysis and it
was all
only um handcrafted in that sense
but then we had another follow-up which
was not published in icml or anything it
was
just an archive and there we wanted to
kind of derive and algorithms that will
find all of these
clusters and all of the options that go
between the clusters
and we called it an abstract mdp because
it has this
you know abstract states and abstract
options
actions and we basically wrote an
algorithm that fits
uh an abstract an abstract mdp to
to the tsne image and we were able to
recover
exactly the same clusters that we
handcrafted
with this type of approach so it was uh
quite nice i think that on the other
hand it was also
disappointing because once we uncovered
this the the structure we weren't able
to do
a lot with it so we tried different
things like trying to you know
control the structure in a way or find
some hierarchical policies on this
structure
um and we didn't succeed too much with
this line of work i worked on it for
about a year after we published
we published the first paper and but it
was very
exciting for me like the revelations
that you know the structures that the
qns learn
has some temporal aspects in it and and
you can
see it so as i understand that there was
let's say an embedding or a
representation which you've learned
and you did a disney projection and you
saw all of this kind of um
aggregations of of various different
state spaces in that game of breakout
but
um in a way that's different to the
structure in the neural network
so the neural network also learns this
entangled hierarchical structure
and is that completely different to the
disney projection or is there a
relationship between
so the tsne projection was just a way
you know to
project the last level of the dqn into a
2d
representation so we can look at it as
humans because you know we are limited
to look at things that are dimensions
and see if we can find the further
structure in it
and so you know this because it's the
last layer it
it includes itself like higher level
features of behavior
and because they are very close to the q
prediction um
and another work that we did was to try
to do better control on top of this
representation so we had a follow-up
paper at nueps where we
you know applied an a linear function
approximation algorithm that is called
list squares policy iteration on top of
this representation and we did
we did got slightly better results from
doing it
so uh i guess that you know my main
takeaway from
this type of folks was that there is
interesting structure that is being
encoded
but it's still not clear how to use it
or or what to do with it
uh which you know like if you take a
fast forward to what we do
with meta gradients we encode the
knowledge in a way that we can use it or
we know how to use it
so the the architecture changed the
algorithm changed
to ways that allows us to you know
leverage all the all the structures that
we
discover fascinating well dr tom zahavi
it's an absolute pleasure and an honor
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you very much thank you i really
hope you've enjoyed the show today we've
had so much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week
you